that was hilarious but guess what it
still wasn't as funny as [__] Brian
Collins Instagram where he says I'm the
Man Dragon dude I did that I put that I
put that up last night holy [__] [__]
man
let's play it because that [__] Brian
Callan is the biggest idiot of all time
I can't even believe this [__] [__]
dude
let's go to his thing I was eating with
my buddies all right
and Brian Callan shows up and we're all
eating together and then he leaves
a real Olive right and we're all
laughing outside at the diner as we do
we [__] laugh outside of the diner
because once you eat and you're done
it's not over [__] the fat lady
hasn't sung yet you go outside
and you you know you do the thing you're
like oh man ah you do that dude because
I'm almost 40. you do that you go
some [__] gets a toothpick because he
thinks he needs it you know
by the way
guys you do that you know and you go oh
[__] that's [__] hilarious man
I don't know man
in there you know
and so Carolyn leaves because he likes
to he loves to pretend like he has [__]
to do at [__] 3am even though he
doesn't and he leaves and he gets goes
walks over to his car
and this happens okay
let me just [__] pull it up again so
I can play it from from the beginning
this happens so he's far away me and my
other two buddies the Irish guy and
Craig
yo
hey that's me obviously what's up Brian
you're a [__] huh
you're a [__]
stay there I'm gonna tell you something
okay so he's far away
now he drives over his car's silent
his Tesla [__] rolls over like it's a
kitty cat Okay pulls up I'm shooting and
I'm good hey bro yeah tonight my comedy
this is what I do to crowds ready hey
you know why they call me the man
dragons
[Applause]
oh
Cinder
's
laughs does this you turn illegally
peace out guys drives away
he [__] Zips by and then has to stop
at a red light
dude
let me tell you something right now
there's nothing that's ever been funnier
than that okay he's 52.
bro he's 52.
he just goes won that one
God damn he's funny man